for some perspective on the Kavanagh
confirmation and more we turn to Bob
Cusack editor-in-chief of the hill
Bob good morning good morning when the
dust clears after this vote after this
brutal 88th day nomination process
where's our government gonna be do you
think I I mean I think this was one of
the ugliest things I've ever seen I'm in
covering politics for for 25 years you
knew it was gonna get ugly but I didn't
think it would get this ugly and both
sides are really blaming the other they
agree we've hit rock bottom but they
were saying little because of them yeah
you know Paula just mentioned it this
idea of the midterms and what this does
for both Republicans and Democrats and
sort of igniting those groups to go out
and vote going into the midterms have we
ever seen a midterm election with this
much scrutiny and this much focus on how
many people will be out to vote no no in
the last midterm in 2014 only 36% of
people showed up that was the lowest in
seven decades 2018 is gonna be very
different I think both sides especially
the left but also the right now very
engaged I think this is gonna be the
closely watched midterm and a lot of
people are gonna show up at the polls
even though it's a month away and that
news cycle we see you're constantly
changing yes
but I think this I mean this boat
yesterday and today it's historic people
are gonna remember it and they're gonna
show up that the poll is one way the
other how intense was the pressure and
those red state Democrats
oh it's it was tough I mean this is a
nightmare scenario for them because
either way they can't win they're in
tough free elections like Joe Manchin
Heidi Heitkamp Manchin both Jess Hyde
camp boats know so this I think in a way
helps the Senate Republican majority
because of the map there are a lot of
red state Democrats who are up however
it hurts House Republicans and their
majority because those are a lot of
swing districts suburban districts this
doesn't play well well how do you think
it affects the midterms at this point
because I mean there's the sense going
into this battle at on the hill was that
that the there was momentum on the
Democrat side but then you started to
see some numbers that suggested there
was Republican momentum because of this
battle yeah where do we left here do you
think well I mean the polls are pretty
even basically this United the
Republican Party even the people who
Republicans who don't like Trump so III
think it just gets the engagement level
up overall I think that Republicans had
to
otherwise the bass would have been
deflated but Democrats say listen this
helps this big time and and this is
gonna cause I mean Democrats haven't
showed up to to vote in a midterm since
2006 I think there's gonna be different
you know we hear so much talk over the
last week we've heard it about this idea
it is supposed to be that someone on the
Supreme Court is nonpartisan but now you
look at a vote like this and people are
talking about the idea that it isn't 60
votes you just need that one extra vote
so has this process become partisan in
that regard that you don't have to sort
of find a Supreme Court nominee that's
in the middle absolutely I mean this
this has changed forever I mean let's
say the Democrats win the Senate okay
and there's another opening on the
Supreme Court Chuck Schumer is not going
to allow that nomination to come to the
floor so we got to see it back and forth
and and the Democrats were the first to
change the nomination process from 60 to
50 and Republicans then did it for the
Supreme Court so this is just an ugly
ugly process that I don't think is gonna
be changing anytime soon there's a lot
to mull over here you have Women Voters
you have conservative voters I'm just
curious the average voter out there what
lessons have been learned here well I I
think it's I think America lost in this
in this debate I mean I just think it
was a really low point for politics and
I think that even though a lot of people
are gonna show up I think the average
voter is why why does this have to be so
contentious the independent voter but
the base they know they were engaged and
and and that's why they're gonna be
engaged in a month Bob Cusack thank you
very much thank you